- And sometimes when I
be telling these stories
I be crying, but I be
crying from the inside.
You never see a teardrop,
but on the inside, I've
been crying all my life.
I've been crying of all my life.
But God's been crying with me.
I've been crying all my life.
- [Mark] All right, David.
David, where'd you grow
up, where are you from?
- I'm originally from San Francisco.
And as I was growing up,
still as the teenager,
a little boy, my mom moved to Pasadena.
But as a kid, I was raised in Pasadena
but I didn't know nothing but Pasadena.
I didn't know if I go too
far where I am, I'm lost.
So I caught a bus one day and this bus
landed me at skid row
on fifth and Broadway.
And it was alive, in 1975.
It was alive, bars open 24 hours a day.
People walking back and forth.
Just a whole bunch of traffic
a whole bunch of activity going on.
- [Mark] What age were you?
- Oh, 17.
Yes. And I lived here in skid row from 17
and may the 12th, I'll be 62 years old.
And I'm still here.
You see 48 years later.
Once I left Pasadena, I
never went back to my family.
I've been out here ever since.
So everybody didn't know where I was.
- [Mark] How was your childhood?
- Oh, my childhood, I
remember a lot of things that
haunted me all my life.
Which is my uncle, one
day was babysitting me
for my mom, cause she was at work.
And he had filled up the bathtub
with water and soap,
bath water, bath soap.
And he was naked and he
had me in there naked
and he had me sitting on top of him.
And my mom she told me she
almost blew his brains out.
Her own brother, when she walked in
and seen him have me naked on his lap.
And she pulled out a gun and she told me.
She hated me ever since what she seen,
she hated me ever since.
- [Mark] She hated you?
- She hated me.
And for what happened to me.
Cause she never, ever got
to know who I really was
because I was afraid.
So I hid many personalities from my mom.
And at the age of six, she was drunk.
And she said, you know what?
I hate you.
I hate you with a passion, you son a bitch
and all this and thing, she cursed me.
I asked her why I would shake the door,
I said, why you hate me, mom?
She said, because of your father.
I hated that motherfucker
for all that he done to me,
beat me in my stomach
so I couldn't have you.
And all of this stuff.
And ever since childhood I've been alone.
I've been here 48 years now.
- [Mark] Your dad?
- I never seen him.
- [Mark] He hit your mom in the stomach?
- Yeah, so she can have a miscarriage.
- [Mark] When she was carrying you?
- Yes, she was pregnant with me.
What happened when he
hit her in her stomach,
it turned me around.
So when she was giving
birth, one of my legs
was stuck inside they were
me out backwards by my leg.
And this leg was inside.
So they didn't want me to drown, in my mom
they had to cut my
mom's vagina wide enough
to take my foot and leg out.
So ever since then, my mom always said,
you know, you've been a hell of a problem
to me ever since you was born.
So in other words, she had to
cut it open and get me out.
My father beat her in her stomach
So, and you know, so she
hated him, so she hated me.
Because she'd say you know what?
You look just like him, you like his twin
and you talk like him, and
I hate that motherfucker
so I hate you too, and
I was six years old.
And these things,
see now I'm a diagnosed
paranoid schizophrenic,
bipolar and all kinds of
things cause of my lifestyle
in downtown here for 48 years,
it did a hell of a toll on me.
But it didn't never make me weak.
It made me stronger.
Cause for 48 years, it
takes a hell of a person
to survive down in an area
like this for 48 years.
- [Mark] Are you living on the street?
- Yes, and underneath
the freeway, in the park
in alleys, in abandoned buildings,
wherever, abandoned car, wherever I can.
- [Mark] Are drugs a part of your life?
- Yes, they is.
When I came down here, I had
never used drugs in my life.
So not even marijuana.
So when I got to down
here, I met some people
and we made friends.
They taught me how to smoke marijuana.
Then they told me how it taught me
how to smoke crack cocaine.
And spice.
Somebody had to show me
how to do these things.
Because I never knew it.
- [Mark] And what is your drug today?
- My drug is spice.
- [Mark] Spice? What
does spice do for you?
- Spice, for me it slows my thinking down.
It slows my thinking down to a point where
I can understand whatever
my mind is trying to
make me understand, I can figure it out.
And this is what I been
doing for 48 years.
I've been figuring people out.
Because there's so many
different personalities
so many different tragedies
happen in front of my eyes.
I was standing closer from me to you,
And this dude pull out a 357 Magnum,
put it to a dude's head, pow,
blew his whole top of his head off
his brain fragmented, splattered
all over the sidewalk.
They were still flapping
because of the nerves.
Blood and water came out,
whew, of the top of his head.
And this thing made me suffer PTSD.
You know, now I suffered.
I take a lot of medication
and in my apartment now
I thank God, I'm not living
on the street no more.
For three years, God has blessed
me with a brand apartment.
So I got a brand new apartment now.
- [Mark] You got housing now?
- Yeah.
- How long has that then?
- Three years.
- Three years?
- Yeah.
- Good for you.
- Cause I get my rent paid automatically,
I don't have to worry about
not having money to pay rent.
They paid my rent for me.
I'm under money management.
So they issue me certain allowances out,
but they keep my money for me.
That's nice, and it's
been over three years
they've been doing it for me.
- [Mark] Do you have children?
- Never, no.
- You ever been married?
- No.
- You ever been in love?
- You feel like you were
ever loved as a child?
So you've never--
- So I've never
knew how love is supposed to feel.
So when somebody told me, one girl told me
I have never had no
sex since 48 years now,
with a female, never
have sex for 48 years.
Why? Because I met one girl when I was 17
and I was in YA,
California Youth Authority.
They took me to the hospital.
She was a secretary, so we got to meet.
And she said, oh, David,
after three days we know each other,
I love you, you're the
only man in my life.
And she led me to believe it.
So I gave all my heart to her.
Cause not knowing any better,
I gave my heart to her.
Then later on down the
relationship, she said,
well I can't see you anymore.
I say what you talking about?
I thought you said you love me.
No, I'm in love, I'm married.
And she showed me a picture
of her, her husband and baby.
I said, you know, it broke my,
it did something mentally to me.
- [Mark] She was married.
- Yeah. It did something mentally to me,
just as well as broke my heart.
So I never trusted women
since 48 years now.
I don't feel like I'm gay or anything.
I don't have no feeling.
It's numb, I don't know how to feel.
You know, everything I went through
I had to feel now I don't want to feel
- [Mark] Would you,
would you call yourself,
would you consider yourself happy?
- Yeah. Yeah, in a way.
Just because of the fact that I know
I'm in contact with God above
and he's been protecting
me ever since 48 years.
- Does that help you?
- Yes, yes.
My belief helps me
overcome a lot of things.
I believe that God is
gonna make a way for me
to make everything alright.
So I just go through the motions,
go through an episode but I know
I'm not going through it alone,
He's going through it with me
and that make me happy.
So I consider myself blessed.
- [Mark] Is this the best
time of your life right now?
- Yes, as I grow old.
As I grow old, yes this is the best time.
When I look in the mirror now,
see these gray hairs in my hair.
I say, damn, David, I remember
when you had all black hair.
And I be talking to myself
while I look in the mirror,
It takes whether or not to
have that shit up there anyway.
All the shit I been through,
it turned my hair gray anyway (laughs).
- [Mark] How old are you now?
- 62, I'll be 63 in May.
- [Mark] What's the most important lesson
you've learned in your life?
- Well, the most important, not to judge.
Not to judge no one.
- That's a good one.
- Not to judge no one
and never turn your eye,
a blind eye, when a person is in need.
Or need of your advice or something.
I get stopped a lot.
And I tell people how to change their life
because of my experience
I have went through.
I say, you know what?
They say how do you get an apartment?
Come on, I take them through the steps.
I say you got to go
through these steps, now.
Now, if you ain't willing to,
you ain't going to get no apartment
And some of them never get an apartment
but you don't want to obey His steps.
But I had to obey a lot of steps
to have an apartment that I got now.
- [Mark] What's your view of
your childhood that you had?
Your dad was out of
your life, your mom was,
- Well,
- do you regret?
- First, yes, I regret.
- having the parents that you did?
- Yeah. Yes. I regret
everything they did to me.
But I forgive them at the same time.
On my mom died, on her death bed
in the hospital, somebody in
the drug pool that I was in
found out where my mind was and
they took me over there to see my mom.
I only seen her for
seven days and she died.
She had Alzheimer's, she don't
even know who I was anyway.
But I just was able to
see her after 48 years.
I see my mom when she was
young and big and healthy.
Now she's frail gray hair and bawled up.
No, I told them no that ain't my mama.
No, that ain't mama.
I couldn't believe that was my mama.
See 48 years, how much 48
years changes a person.
And sometimes when I be
telling these stories,
I be crying, but I be
crying from the inside.
You'd never see a teardrop,
but on the inside, I've
been crying all my life.
I've been crying all my life.
But God's been crying with me.
And I tell everybody that.
They say, you seem so happy, David.
It's just, if you only knew.
if you only knew,
If you only knew is I'm not happy.
- [Mark] Do you feel like all the things
you've been through have
helped make you stronger?
- Yes. The abuse made me stronger.
The neglect made me stronger.
The lack of love made me stronger.
The kindness made me stronger.
You know, everything made me stronger.
God made it right for me,
everything right for me.
- [Mark] What emotions do you deal with?
Do you get depressed sometimes?
- No, I tried not to get depressed.
I go walking or something or recycling.
I don't like to feel depression, no.
I take right now hypertension
pills for depression.
- [Mark] So you you've had
depression in the past?
- Yes.
- The medication helps you?
- [Mark] What was your favorite memory?
- To tell you the truth, I don't have one.
I was trying to think of one, but I can't.
No, I can't, I don't know.
Oh, okay, I found out one.
When I went and purchased
me a little duck.
So I have my little duck in my apartment
it's living in the bathroom.
He's poo-pooing every damn where.
And I'm like oh hell now, I can't even
walk in my bathroom
without stepping in it.
But I raised him from little chick
all the way to like this, a big, big duck.
So, I mean, he was like a dog.
He was like a dog.
I was like, come here, come here
he'll look at me, I say,
come here, come here.
He look he'll, he'll go.
He'll come to me, he'll
stay right by my leg.
And nibble on my pant,
but he'll come to me.
I had it for a month, but my
therapist, my psychiatrist
told me, David, let's
take them to a shelter.
I said, take him to a
shelter, no, for what?
Cause he's getting too big, he's too big
and your apartment is too
small for him to run around.
He needs space.
I let her talk me into
taking him to a shelter.
So that was one of my joyfullest times.
Being able to watch him
grow and talk to him,
and he respond.
- [Mark] Given the life that you've had,
do you feel like life is unfair?
- Well, I don't know
if it's fair or unfair.
I don't know.
I don't know how to answer
if it's fair or unfair.
I just know life is life.
Life is life.
Life is what it is.
You can't change it.
So why try to figure it out?
Just go along with life and
you'll be better off (laughs)
- [Mark] All right, David,
thank you so much for sharing your story.
- Oh, you welcome.
Thank you man, for having me.
- [Mark] Yeah. Very interesting.
- Yeah.
- Thank you very much.
- See, and everything I
told you is from my heart.
A lot of secrets I hope I
wouldn't let certain people know
but the ones who don't need
to know, they will never know.
But I let you know what I'm all about.
- Thank you very much.
- You're welcome.